um let's go to
kellen from ukraine are you in ukraine
kellen
hi david can you hear me yes i can
um
i live in kiev and i've lived there for
the last 11 years
um
but i actually came back to the us for
business on february 1st oh okay
but my wife
my cat and all of her family are still
in ukraine she actually just got out of
kiev
uh with an armed guard last week
and went to the west
wow and do you like so okay talk me
through the logistics of that do you
hire an armed guard to help your wife
get to the west of the country
so her dad is fairly well connected um
he's
a uh
director of a regional hospital in
western ukraine okay so he has a lot of
people who owe him favors i see and so
he was able to talk to one of his
connections uh who happened to be in
kiev at the time of the invasion
and he had special military permission
to be out after curfew
and he was also allowed to carry a
concealed weapon so he came to our
apartment
and took our car
with my wife and cat and some of her
belongings so the cat went with your
wife that's good to hear at least
now let me ask you this
have you have you abandoned not you but
have you together as a unit
are you planning to go back to kiev when
um
as soon as
the
proper number of russians have been sent
home in body bags
wow
so in other words you're not abandoning
kiev you're just waiting for the
violence to end
yeah and i i left there on february 1st
for business purposes to come back to
the u.s yeah and was
was planning on returning but
um it's not it's not possible i mean
it's very hard to even get back into
kiev right now even if you want to
unless you have some kind of
military protection and i i'm not a
trained soldier um i and the ukrainian
government has asked weekend warriors to
stay away yeah and that's exactly what i
would be so i'm respecting that uh that
call from the government and are you
american married to a ukrainian woman or
are you ukrainian
i'm american married to ukrainian i have
residency in the country okay um
yeah we we have a couple of apartments
in kiev um
a rocket that was fired into the city
uh landed near our bank which is about
two blocks away from our uh our home oh
and
destroyed quite a bit of it and knocked
out all the windows in the surrounding
area so so can you talk a little bit
about you know in the news we see
russia has has bombed random apartment
buildings and then later you'll hear the
the attempt at a rationalization by
saying well we believe dissidents
and combatants were planning violent
activities in those apartment buildings
do you know anything about that is it
literally just like all of a sudden just
a missile hits an apartment building
uh so the territorial defense forces are
set up basically in every district in
the city
so there are
people who have weapons on the ground in
quite a few places in the city but
like i just saw um
the destruction around lukiana
lukianovka metro station which is about
10 minutes away from our apartment yeah
and
um
i didn't see any military on the ground
near that metro station but it wouldn't
surprise me if
there were
territorial defense forces in and around
that area because it is a major metro
station
it's fairly deep so in a literal sense
when russia says well
those apartment buildings
in or right outside of them had
uh
forces ukrainian forces
uh
every
room of every building in ukraine right
now
has people that are willing to kill
russians in it right right right right
so it just sort of yeah wow
wow all right and then so and for the
time being you're just hanging tight in
the u.s
yeah i'm actually i'm in austin with my
younger brother um
and
you know still trying to go about
business life as as much as i can i've
been doing quite a few
interviews with uh with local media back
in my home state of nebraska
just trying to get the word out and this
was actually part of my
what uh what i wanted to ask you about
is
i have first-hand experience of living
in that country for 11 years um get
getting to know thousands of ukrainians
um
and never seeing any kind of
neo-nazi movements or anything
other than the very far right which like
the azov battalion does have
uh very right-wing
leanings and there are some people but
not any more so than than there are in
any other country in the world i mean
their jewish president got i think it
was 71 or 73 percent of the vote
so
i've talked with a lot of people in the
u.s
who are just
repeating ad nauseam
the same russian propaganda that i got
to hear aplenty uh from
russian media and are the people
repeating that stuff in the us and your
experience do they tend to be more on
the right or the left in the us
tinfoil hat right-wingers every single
one okay okay okay
my question is if if i can't convince
them
um
having lived in the country for 11 years
participated in the maidan revolution
on the ground
and
i actually have first-hand knowledge of
this kind of stuff what hope is there
for any kind of
[Music]
intelligent conversation
about
when we should put boots on the ground
when we should go in there how much
protection we should provide them why we
should care about them if i can't
convince them of that
what hope is there of anyone else to
convince them no regardless of your
views as to what the answers to those
questions should be uh with the people
you're describing you're not going to be
able to have a real sensible
conversation about those issues sadly
but you're just not
all right yeah
well thanks for taking my call for
listening all right well listen let's
hope everybody in the family and uh
everybody in ukraine stays safe okay
all right cheers all right there is
kellen who lives in ukraine